well hello there reject nation I'm Greg
Alba and I'm Renee Arielle Renee do you
ever watch Family Guy no have you seen
family god of course I just don't have
cable it's not on cable but ok is it on
Fox
oh I thought it was on Comedy Central
well do you have television I don't have
TV I have basic cable I say I don't have
any kind of like base I just don't have
streaming oh no I have like I think I
like ten or twelve channels I just said
Oh weird I want like this two four five
seven nine eleven guy challenge you I
don't really do try it to life
challenges but I've actually really been
into the Family Guy once because I
genuinely find them actually pretty
difficult to actually get through who
can their time so I'm really having to
fight it does react Chows would be like
so many of them throughout the week but
like literally family guys the only what
I've been doing let's bring Renee on for
the challenge try it I'm gonna really
try not to laugh though so yeah we'll
see who win deadpan serious you [ __ ]
boring [ __ ] watching ball Renee on
Instagram guys it's worth it Twitter
it's worth it
she's part of the new trendy thingy this
is it's in the description box worth it
go check it out let's do it
are you nervous oh yes arse over do not
smile I can't smile you have to fight
this month yeah you can't you can't like
cheat your laugh through okay I won't
smile and if you if you [ __ ] up just
start again okay alright it's a real
competition if it is
[Music]
[Music]
getting my van and I'll give you some
candy no I shouldn't hey kid get in my
van I'll give you some candy I want to
get married
[Music]
[Music]
okay me whenever I get any Greg don't do
some [ __ ] dancing
[Music]
I wish I was a bigger Footloose fan yeah
I've never seen that I know what it is
well I can identify with the the act God
sometimes you just got a dance right
I don't know what it is but you have got
issues Thank You fallen and can't get up
turns out still using that joke is a
felony guess I better not drop the soul
that wants the death penalty as a result
I've rediscovered an old hobby I used to
love as a kid then Trebek whistle and I
wanted to invite you guys to the opening
of my new show of the Quahog playoffs
quite mine we've been delighted to
attend what a mission thanks Peter
means a lot okay
[Music]
this is gonna be torture like you I
couldn't even figure out the
self-checkout at the supermarket please
place the item in the bagging area
please remove the item from the bagging
area please take a plastic bag from the
bagging area please put the bag over
your head and tighten I told you I could
make him do it that's hardcore man
you're hardcore looping gif of black
teens reacting to a very mild burn it's
kind of pointless oh you mean like
you're taking or liking
[Applause]
[Music]
have fun Brian no he was a wet blanket
and I'm standing that you might be right
Brian's getting old it's not the dog he
used to be and I have to get used to it
just like I got used to my acrylic nails
[Music]
[Music]
she is it's not yours
oh oh wow
Todd you came at the at the right moment
this is Todd you guys have no idea
what's going on this cat Oh
switching sides huh he's switching sides
oh no no destroy suffer he's never come
up to anyone who sat next to me really
really I don't know if you're just
pulling your leg goes up to like their
tabs or something and like rubs up and I
can't just sit on that's that's never
happened we ever cat yourself or can I
say I'm the cat lady the cat lady is a
cat lady
[Music]
yeah you have gets or maybe they added I
feel like cats kind of just feel that
vibe talking about this yeah they're
just talking about the cat going on your
lap that was awesome good job Todd
appreciate it maybe he just wants food
I'm not sure what it is hey you know
what most of that was actually really
easy it's normally a lot harder to do I
did a good job
I found out hard when the cat got on my
lap cuz then I wanted to smile yeah cat
was watching going and he make this
little more challenging for him the one
that really got me that I've never seen
this family guy bit which was the
ventriloquist doll one oh that one those
funny when you're like [ __ ] do
something I don't know how the rest of
the states of the world of us and a are
but in California especially a lot of us
say yes to a lot of things that we
ultimately just don't care to be a part
of oh for sure so this felt close to
home I really liked actually the first
Alma Stewie oh yeah oh so early on yeah
and I was like oh this is gonna be hard
I don't really do this but I did get
through it that would that one almost
broke me though I thought that was
really funny the self-checkout one too
oh yeah that was good I know where that
one was going at first and I was like oh
boy I hate self-checkout machine why I
use them all the time and it's just
never I always have to call a [ __ ]
attendant for someone would you there's
always something that's like complicated
to just scan like today I almond they'll
get Target and it's oh you ordered yeah
well Ralph I do other PBS CBS is myself
yes as the good put that bag over your
head and kill it says oh it always
thinks it's like I rewrite scan
something you know that I have to put
the item in the section so it could like
you feel the different weight
distribution and never does it never
doesn't it's always like just good right
oh my good spirits book that's what
happens when it's really light though if
you buy something like very like gum
yeah it can't sense it it's black you're
done learn your job bird job artificial
intelligence but I really identify with
that
whole thing of just like [ __ ] yeah yes I
like that they kept the bit going to
yeah I don't want to go see my friends I
don't want to go to flapper Zinberg make
one more time hey you did great Rene I
feel like you're trying not to laugh
face was a great success thank you I
think you're gonna make everyone really
happy
kudos the cat loves you I love you the
fans love you
everyone loves you Rene and if you
really love Rene you should go check her
out
I'm the trendy channel that is called
the trendy cheer my god Greg the trendy
it's just the trendy we've filmed two
other videos same thing happened this is
the best he's done though the trendy
channel check it out the trendy little
arch right oh damn jim has over a
million subscribers really oh my gosh
what the hell are you doing here yes I
start when this goes up I'll already
have some news videos up but if you want
to keep up with me on the daily I've got
Instagram and Twitter yeah yeah go check
her out over there people please well
worth it do that now yep right now we're
waiting subscribe and subscribe like
notification bells on we'll see you soon
keep the trend go it doesn't cut
automatically